welcome to this video yes this is
five-minute action here on the ICC what
do we get the laws and opening young one
be three let's see yeah this is a bit of
a wacky set up with Bishop t6 but it's
pretty it's pretty good black gets this
regrouping in with Bishop back to f8 and
then you can organize his center quite
reliably with flexible most e 60 d 50
that's an interesting way to play yeah
because it keeps it lets this bishop and
the bishop there makes a stronger the
weird impression that won't be five ok
let's play it simple that cannot be bad
for me yep they can just take stuff here
and have a good position with two
bishops ok so what do I do I can take it
hmm it's an interesting question if i
should actually trade queens or not you
will take with the bishop down
now that's a bit lame it's a bit lame to
trade but there it's not bad it just it
just as the set it's a bit lame yeah
standard time of endgame two bishops
against them against them better and at
least on paper better structure I mean
like else has no problems here it's just
not easy to to get something with b5
might be an idea
yeah probably i will trade one pair of
rooks there okay he wants to go to you
for maybe I don't know Brooke the ADA's
good anyway and what is this dear Knight
to c3 yeah yeah I'm not quite sure here
if I want to trade everything I mean all
rooks the point hmm Jim I'm a bit unsure
but that's not a bad idea I don't at
least it's no problem whatsoever yeah b5
do I get this and I I will I only am a
bit unsure how to do that exactly okay I
tried to get the King King to c6 first
it looks a bit awkward but shouldn't be
bad I can start with c 6 & B then B fire
I wonder that's a possibility Kings is 6
90 95 is a bit awkward I have be five
button yeah probably i cannot play
without c6 anyway yeah so here we go
Jim difficult it's difficult to do
something really in terms of playing for
when I mean hmm yeah I was threatening
Bishop to d2 so he is trying drawing for
something ok I can take this pawn is am
i trapped there then or I don't don't
see it mmm Bishop takes at 5i take g3 I
don't see why I shouldn't take check ok
so he wants to try to trade this down to
some kind of draw I can go here though
for g6
taking i think is ticking wasn't an
option so let's go back maybe here I
don't know where okay and the question
is do I go g5 or not probably okay this
is making sense probably in any case and
then g5 you have to go back threatening
g5g for possibly he might take but that
just opens the position still not easy
to win this even after his after he gave
me the pawn shop over to f7 so that
there's pressure on uncie form try to i
try to optimize the piece position here
I be should be five huh if there was a
chance but I've played it a bit bit too
quickly ok so H for or not can try to
get the bishop around and probably not
do a good job i hear g4 and then the
bishop the other way i don't know
probably not how do i win out where
winders before it's not good
can try to invite them i don't i don't
see I don't see a way forward that's
really a shame okay I tried that just
just because I want to what the draw but
i'm not sure if it is any good ok ok
trying this and then come up with the
King King g7 King to g5 and I have to
let Bashar 78 I have to get this counter
check in now I'm going up g5 and h4 now
time is the 0 Bishop f4 me me yeah okay
that's that's that's unfortunate kind of
a this is the kind of the way to win
such a game with white you just sit
there do nothing the whole game instead
of running into a checkmate okay that's
funny yeah I saw it when I played it but
yeah of climbing came like just win cm
it's nothing nothing to be said about
that i think i should win this but why
would how now maybe it's not that easy
it's maybe not that easy still it looks
really bad because white is tied down
here to see form and I have this age for
idea but okay I cannot go age for here
this is not going to work yeah okay so
maybe a bishop d6 was winning yet I
could have won anyway this but should be
five earlier that that was the
opportunity that I didn't take but this
wins I have Bishop b5 d for now yeah
okay
there was one very clear opportunity
when I was just playing too quickly here
Bishop b5 is just that wins the game if
I get the bishop activated and deny him
this opportunity to put the bishop 1c3
this is too much the pawn the extra porn
would win this end game yeah he just
gave away aged three around here this is
just a situation where it's difficult to
do anything black has the two bishops
but it's um it's difficult difficult to
get something going in the whole
situation is probably relatively dry I
mean okay just blundered the the h3 porn
which she you just have to play King f3
trying to play for win ear for wider
some it's not realistic anyway can be a
can be glad if you get the draw p.m.
yeah king of three Bishop f5 can you to
this probably the logical end of this
because black also has no way to win
after g3 of course yeah black is much
better but ran into a crazy checkmate
okay well thanks for watching